welcome back well it's day two of ces
2021 and although it's all virtual this
year there is no shortage
of great devices we talked to one expert
about this year's trends which a big
focus is health
and a few you might want to add on your
must-get list
this is eight on your site
it's the super bowl of technology ces is
all virtual this year but that's not
holding back any devices
from the spotlight there's a lot of new
technologies much of it is dealing with
health
of course because of the pandemic a big
trend according to consumer technology
expert dr frank vigiano
are devices with uvc light which have
the ability to clean
and sanitize this is a portable uvc wand
that's really what it is
and you'll notice i've opened it up and
as i glide it let's say over an object
if i take this object
and of course you don't want to get it
near your skin similar concept can be
seen on a much
bigger scale to help sanitize the home
and even the classroom
but they're all also new products to
make our lives easier the biggest
problem
with electric vehicles today is
something referred to as battery anxiety
it's called
ax fast this happens to be a 32 amp
level 2 charger
what does that mean it has a 240 volt
plug on the end
with a 24 foot cord but it allows you to
charge the vehicle
anywhere the pandemic has also forced
many folks to redesign their homes
and las vegas-based company mirage
vision wants to help with a new
outdoor indestructible television these
tvs
they've installed them at the mgm at
caesars and they will be installing
at the new resorts world as well but
they come in 4k
and they the other thing is cool too
they're 10 times brighter by the way
than your standard
tv at home and they come in sizes from
32 inch
to 200 inch cloudless portable hard
drives and even a water brake alarm
system rounds out
our list visit 8newsnow.com for other
new products
i love that tvs christian are
indestructible